a delight to be joined by a bee brooch
and Joel excellent ashlar I never
pronounced that one right you guys
Borderlands the pre-sequel coming out
like a month's time about three weeks
ago yeah they're close I was feeling so
we were having a conversation about this
cuz you're a big fan of well came up
with all the Destiny stuff of like co-op
for player first pursuit errs and I was
being really reductive thinking alright
there's new board lads coming out looks
really like the old Borderlands and then
you put out that trailer last week and
it was like eight minutes of new
features yeah is that like kind of an
important thing where you guys are like
trying to push the fact that there's
actually a buttload of new stuff going
on in Borderlands the pre-sequel there's
been a ton of work that's going to get
even that trailer doesn't contain all
the new features that we've put in there
I don't think we have a grinder in there
or any of the grinder isn't it oh is it
yeah this I I handled my p's and q's oh
that's right I got [ __ ] on lock it's
fine but yeah it's it's a totally new
game it we use photo lens to as the
starting point engine wise we made
completely new are we have completely
new characters vehicles we brought lean
lasers cryo plus the low gravity I think
Chris he had some hands-on I know at
least at least once a couple months ago
oh yeah I played a lot of but stomping
phone at a pax prime actually it was
really interesting because the low
gravity you know it's not like there's a
floaty jump right so you jump but you
also run faster and you can do this sort
of but stomp smash maneuver so really
like I think movement is one of the like
if you change movement in the game you
change the fundamental way you interact
with the game yeah so that's definitely
something they got going on here yeah
the basic core loop isn't about cover
anymore it's not about standing behind
things awaiting for your shield to
regenerate it's about like you have all
these tools at your disposal now to get
behind enemies cover and screw with them
and when you stop they get just stunned
for a second so instead of like I don't
want to get shot so I'll hide behind a
thing now it's I don't want to get shot
so we'll get right in their faces and do
things to them like freeze them or but
stomp them or punch them that's done
them essentially or pop their you know
their their their helmet that makes them
started fixating it seems like a four
character as well are a lot like varied
more so than previous board lands
they're always different than out there
you know don't class abilities one out
but it seems like the fundamental sort
of player them is actually quite
different absolutely it was actually we
took kind of a different person to what
gearbox took with Bolin's one ball ends
to with the playable characters where we
started from the narrow
point and then build the characters from
there so actually go all their skills
with their personalities in mind in the
history in mind in claptraps a perfect
example of that where he has this kind
of buggy software that's unpredictable
and kind of scary and and really useful
but sometimes it can be like why what is
he doing what was the thing about the
like the the bouncing by accident yes
sometimes claptrap will go into rubber
ducky mode and it will make everyone on
his team they'll repel bullets which is
nice but they'll also be bouncing up and
down uncontrollably which is [ __ ]
irritating but you'll also be able to
but slam all the time while you're in
the air so you kind of get to do more
damage that way but if like one of your
friends goes down you're trying to
revive them and you can't stay right
because you're bouncing up and down and
I really loved it was a pretty light
addition to the game that when that
happens the other players get you thin
claptraps appear on this screen right
because he's the worst yeah well we
actually have one of your boys in the
back playing so let's check out the
gameplay yeah so right at the mower
we're in concordia which is kind of like
the hub on elpis so this is where a lot
of NPCs oh it's where Moxie hangs out
it's where Janie who's kind of the moon
mechanic examine we're actually going to
do a mission for her so Jeff's playing
over there in the background he's really
good at falling off ledges and dying but
he can probably go accept this mission
as well so this is janie and we can't
hear it over here but it anyone the
stream can tell she's she's a good
Australian Janie so is it so a lot of
people on the moon yeah it's not the
only one who's a bit Australian you guys
have basically made space Australia it
was too good a juried into the
experience okay you're off to taste
really yeah i remote from Canberra in
Australia so it's 2k strongly working
with gearbox and we kind of we focused a
lot on the moon part in the gearbox and
focused a lot on the Hyperion Space
Station right and it's actually been a
really fun experience because we have a
lot of riding happening in Australia for
the moon it's not like heavy rain it's
not like they can pretending to be
American but all the children are French
for some reason at a certain point in
the you know we were doing our own
leaning a nice voice over that you know
just temporary voiceover trying to do
like the Australian side and the
American side in there like we did a
terrible job of the American side great
I don't know Cowboys homophobia I think
yeah well there ya
pretty much it no that's the best what
Australians think Americans are like
right that's why I soon as the subtext
run throughout the game no it's kind of
just that one time I was a little bit
surprised that I played that mission ish
I felt like I felt like Maurice America
guys who wrote all the Australia and
level stuff he would know part but I i
wrote this that that line you just heard
the homophobia one I like those guys are
so nice and so just generally genial but
they'll never make fun of us in that way
but it's okay to call us all done it
loving homophobes and oh yeah i mean
they're the most self deprecating people
in the office mr. Merrick so it's okay
we can make fun of effort of each other
that's kind of the borderlands away yeah
like yeah what you're all or open two
skewers yeah equal opportunity make fun
of anyone okay now this just looks
pretty nice including this weeks front
of yourself as well yeah the claptrap on
this yes Mike should think the
animations for getting him to get into
and out of vehicles way harder than
anybody don't really want you were just
like you'll just welcome like the same
Reagan's like no this is months of work
because it needs to look cool and even
like when you crash as claptrap he goes
into a show like a total as well yeah so
um right now Jeff is going down the
middle tree for clap peplum I love you
guys which again be like like Joel's
saying a lot of the character skills are
based off of their personalities so this
middle tree is all about the fact that
nobody likes class coaches the stuck to
me desperately wants friends so it's all
about buffing his teammates and trying
to basically convince them to love him
the very very top tier skill that we
won't get to see is he asked for a high
five from his friends that they
high-five and then everybody gets buffs
Anthony will never have fun I will never
have 55 / says he's the worst I mean you
can you can like claptrap you could also
like you know big bang theory and you
can drive your car they're all kinds of
decisions you can make in your life that
I want judge you for you just wait wrong
is that a CBS property yes yea yea i
meant to say was you going on any
quality sounds like you're broke girls
in big bank berries and everybody loves
raymond non-stop for five hours they
make a soon that's when you get higher
they force that on yeah Oh miss a minute
this is over I'm on Big Bang our so see
uh that was a different show actually
Jeff is using the Stingray which is one
of our new vehicles and you can actually
usually in berlin's the special ability
button makes you boost to go faster
button this it actually makes you jump
I just also Elias Oh God is really
looking the only thing uh grace so good
at this Jeff you didn't even show the
slam if you hold if you hold the right
bumper as well you can don't go back way
now that moment have any of you guys
played unreal tournament 2004 yes yeah
yeah that's exactly like that is a canon
sequel on earth this is all the Leandre
company so we're doing a mission for
Janey at the motorway she needs to make
some motivational posters yeah it was
just a silly way of like teaching the
jump pads and we've got like what's an
excuse for you to just do a jump pad and
almost nothing else so we thought it
would be funny for you to like have to
pose for inspirational posters by
jumping in the air and then you won't
see it but in the follow-up quest you
then go around a bandit camp posting up
inspirational posters of yourself and
depending on what character you are the
poster is different and your commentary
is different because this time around
your characters actually say stuff about
the plot they're not just battle
dialogue spouting machines I really have
things to say male character arcs that
are different yeah this one's really
good example if you place you the
different characters she asked me to say
something motivational if I don't get
taken it every single character to say
something different I think Nisha says
something about like strangling puppies
yeah tribe is so earnest oh one word for
BM and oh my god Jeff really gonna do it
okay there you go you did it he got it
he got there eventually and his bunch
more of writing the weapons as well both
all that I stuff is that new yeah so we
added laser weapons into the game which
go across all the manufacturers and all
the different weapon pieces so you have
all that different variety but we also
had a cryo which is guns the enemy's
grenades on like I stuff so you can
actually freeze and shatter yes third
time's the charm this isn't the hex game
that we were watching Elias isn't it i
can see must just be a joy to play video
games with you yeah yeah i'm very
forgiving of people i play co-op with
yeah just take your blood money and go
so yeah I mean it's actually honestly
kind of heart will see coming up when
you actually start shooting some people
but um it's really hard for me as
somebody who spent a lot of time playing
borderlands 2 during its development to
go back to borderlands 2 anymore I you
know miss when I go back to just being
able to jump over big swathes of the
level just to get two objectives i miss
you know not being able to immediately
get behind an enemy if I want to I miss
having I really don't miss in borland
three sequel having to take cover and
stuff because this isn't find that
boring was the first person shooter like
development cabal that they all just
decided this year was the year of the
it's a great job yeah yeah i think our
double jump is the only one with a butt
slam though rights are winning all right
yeah you guys are definitely the butt
slam pioneers yes that is a [ __ ] i will
happily hang on my and we have a buck
stomping vehicle as well so you can
actually show that now i don't go
splatter someone Jeff don't mess it up
Jeff yeah I mean we make these games so
fast and you know we do focus s and
everything but we just found that like I
kind of accidentally we just changed the
cold loop of borderlands by adding this
low gravity because the enemies do it as
well they jump over and then slam onto
you and you're just every time you enter
a space it's different you no longer
like scouting and say oh I'm gonna hide
beyond here and take out this guy like
I'm going to try and get to the top of
this building and then slam down and
free some guys and shatter them yeah
it's way more effective to just keep
moving and get into two phases which is
honestly the way I always played
borderlands but just I ended up dying a
lot in this time my game just goes at
school especially for flying is somebody
like Athena where the more damage she
takes the more powerful she is if you've
got any questions for the guys please by
all means put them in the gang smart
comments or in the twitch chat and we'll
scrub scrub yourself Jeff oh my god Jeff
you got any questions or motivating
really good momentum going go go back oh
you even jump that's with space to spare
I but so I got to play it a bunch and
you know you're right about the enemies
getting up in your face I mean there's
always been psychos and that run at you
and are throwing axes and stuff but
there are psychos that now jump in but
stop you yeah and then you are you're
getting the status like your your shield
is breaking in your face there's a lot
of stuff that's up in your face so it
kind of it does spur you on to be like
oh you want to get up in my face yeah
I'm getting your face
not gonna wait for you just to be like
oh that guy's behind cover I Bay just
stay right here and wait for him to pop
up they're just going to try and jump up
and stump you out of there as well so
you know given that that increased since
that sort of focus on getting in
people's faces and that rewarding that
kind of mobility is there still a place
for snipers in this game for popping
heads from that off yeah I think puppy
heads is even more satisfying because
are you doing it from a distance you can
pop that air bubble and watch them
suffocate if you're into that kind of
thing right Jeff you're not supposed to
kill them in this mission Jack Jack
you're the dumbest boy in the world so
the point of this mission if you're not
the dumbest boy in the world is to hit
the crag Anse with the Prague gun it's a
special gun that you get and then get
them to run into the door to bet blasted
open for you okay so let's see if Jeff
can do that one Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff I
believe in you oh yeah oh boy I finally
was saying earlier this is your last
shot and this is Big Bang quality all
right we're gonna exactly it didn't
wonder it's wonder it's the best thing
that's ever happened television so we go
ahead oh you're up girl would one take
and ship it yeah you got to do it again
jeffer standing around playing do it
again it was a really good idea to
change up the mission we were showing
there we go okay you did it get it I'm
tagging nice good editor at what step
right in all do it just do it just go in
there that's fine one of the
conversations we were having a lot with
the week that's in it it was a bad
destiny sort of loot system hey you guys
seem to have come up with a pretty good
workaround for when you pick up stuff to
you don't necessarily want yeah the
grinder grind area you want talk about
the grinder oh yeah so it's it's kind of
a way you know you can mark stuff that
you don't want to keep as you collect it
and you can just sell that quickly when
you go back to a store or you can look
for items of you know the similar colors
and put them in the grinder try and get
something better we also have you know
some special recipes which we we hope
the community are going to you know I'm
sure a day after the game comes out
there before and post a like here are
all the awesome recipes to use to get
people legendaries for shields and for
class mods in four and four guns and
everything so it's not totally random or
is it mostly random and under some
specific there are some specific recipes
and will
making some more as well but ya know I
think it's it's a good way for forgot we
were going to show this this is so
dramatic and so great for streaming go
ahead catch borderlands fever everybody
right I like it and I don't see but you
only need yeah oh yeah straight out a
monster truck rally like yeah it's on a
Ledge there we go the guy who does
torgue voiceover just like work one day
on vocal rest for two weeks every day
yeah he the dudes name is Chris Traeger
he's like the sweetest dude ever if you
watch dragonball z he's also the voice
of a mr. satan dragon ball and he's just
a sweetheart who really likes doing
mister torgue he doesn't like physically
enjoy he likes having done it but he's a
really fun guy so yeah like just like in
Borderlands 2 we have a lot of quests
that have branching ends so you can get
different rewards and different plot you
know rewards like that doesn't happen if
you go give the thing to Janie springs
instead you get a laser gun and she's
nice to you instead of a thing exploding
and after you wait for like 20 minutes
so depending on if you're like an
efficient gamer who wants to not have
your time wasted by seeing an animation
like that then you can go turn into
ginnie springs or if you like you know
mister torgue then you can do that
instead I got a bunch question some what
kind of make sure we cover a couple of
them as zombie 97 lv asks watered
vehicles are there in the game and
you've shown a bit of a sort of the
navigation with them additions to combat
and stuff with the vehicles well i guess
with the the Stingray you have that
pancake attack where you know we have
specific challenges about trying to
splatter certain amount of enemies you
have yalls government buggy yeah we've
got the moon buggy as well which does we
kind of tailored to the terrain to do
some pretty awesome jumps and kind of
fulfill that that promise of driving a
moon buggy and and going in low gravity
you can also get a cryo rocket launcher
on the as your secondary weapon on these
and that's pretty cool because if you
have like a
moon banded or a creature you can freeze
them solve them and just drive straight
through them in the ispotter of your
windshield yeah the ice particle effects
of like even support you freezing them
you punch them and then they go in that
direction it's district is really
satisfying when you're quite numerous
athena and you freeze some way and use
your sword it will actually just slide
off as well oh really I samurai shodown
style you guys must get these questions
every single time one of these games
comes out Curtis I will you be seeing
some of the original vault hunters
obviously this kind of straddle the line
between the two games as well yeah yeah
we showed in some of the trailers to
roll in the world are hanging out and
they will enter into the plot in pretty
cool way I think Randy spoiled is a
gentle word the fact that the the entire
game is basically it's a meshed in a
frame narrative where Athena is talking
to Lilith after Borderlands 2 after josh
is already dead and brick and mortar car
hanging out there and stuff is Goliath
feeding still in the game mask so soon
alive feeding ya know like kiting that
may be like farming yeah you sort of
like get the Goliath to kill more [ __ ]
he was alright powerful now glides not
on the moon got a bunch of new other
enemies on Conrad yeah so we just went
through demons something wasn't
Australia called Van Diemen's land doors
at estimating nu has been denied ok
really good actually yes my name is
worldly ass [ __ ] hell yeah
gotten gotten esoteric don't let you
know that Tasmania is a play hey we know
about the devil yeah I played Sega
Genesis yes yeah that that's not just
the Dean habitants of the moon there's a
lot of Australian places and legendary
weapons in this is actually is actually
a talking weapon which is the most vile
Australian piece of anything that's been
really I didn't erase any kind of
entertainment product in history called
bogan Ella I didn't know about Jeff you
should go find some scabs that you can
fight like on your feet with your guns
it looks like you guys wanna get dumped
let's start sort of a remarkable amount
of free rein in relation to what's
actually happening because mechanically
there seems to be quite a lot
different yeah well I mean octopus we've
been working with your box the entire
time on the game in the whole aim for
was to make a totally new game that
feels you know fresh not just this
portal Lance but as a completely new
game coming up Christmas time so I had
to change up the mechanics in and not
just you know the low gravity changed up
the combat but you also have skills and
level design and everything that comes
along with that but you know I mean
basically my god we've been given the
go-ahead to make a fun game yeah and
it's been really awesome okay sup pop
goes the weasel and there you go okay so
that's the clap in the box if you get
back your boxes man I knew a girl to a
club in the box I'm sure she's very
sweet oh if that explodes and you don't
kill an enemy you got okay don't you go
in to fight for your life mode so it's a
thing where we've had people around me
on the office that that are correct and
also don't like claptrap where they
think it's funny too when you get a clap
in the box to go oh [ __ ] everybody kill
all the enemies around him excellent and
that to be clear that vault net
claptraps vault hunter skill is like
many different things depending on the
situation yeah if you get something
different yea you can see when this
comes up it's trying out whether analyze
the situation and sometimes it imitates
other vault hunters action skills other
times it's totally weird kind of makes
up what do you think all understand so
that one it's harder to tell the laser
guns but that one is gun wizard and it
makes your fire rate ridiculous and if
you're in a team then everybody's fire
rate gets ridiculous there are other
ones like one shot wonder where every
time you pull your trigger once that's
active you expel all the bolts in your
gun in a single shot and it blows you
back a little bit which if you're in the
air when you do it it's pretty fun
especially cuz claptrap is another skill
where if he gets mail a hit then he
basically it releases a sort of digital
what is it was like a digital fart thing
that's what the leg Questor that the
mission tech says earth the skill text
Oh is there was a moment where I was
fighting an abandoned we jumped in the
air and he hit me the same time that I
did my one shot wonder we just want
people away from each other like like
poetry in the sky accepted a farting
robot I wish we kind of had built in
slow motion just in case but yeah yeah
yeah what's it like for you guys
considering like borderlands is a
massive fan base
fans and obviously this is the the third
game in the considering like when you
guys started doing this there was the
first person four player co-op thing was
kind of a new novel concept at least in
terms of like farming getting loot and
stuff like in this post destiny world
like what's the sort of muder and
gearbox and 2k Australian relation to
that like is that something you even
feel like you have to kind of tackle at
all like I mean would you have your own
thing going on I mean thankfully I mean
we you know we were working on this
before definitely came out sort of is
what it is independent but I mean I
certainly we talked a lot about it at
work because uh you know it's just the
game that everybody's playing but I
think they're so different inherently
what they're trying to do both tonally
and in terms of like the loot loop and
you know what our overall goals are so
different destinies goals I feel like
anybody could say they coexist peace
yeah yeah I think that they're totally
their first person trees which have
co-opted they're they're totally
different excellence at every student
right second week of yes yeah the real
teeth of October here in the States 16th
in Australia and then 17th everywhere
else great at a pasty Australian radio
ratings board yeah I hopes all good
pretty sure ain't dead then I've been
sketchy in there no you know maybe we
slip them some money into the table okay
oh nice work gentlemen thank you so much
coming in Joel ashlar pleasure to meet
you thank you burst pleasure to meet you
again I will not shake hands because I
know you're sick yeah thanks for a
comment on it and better luck with your
community and whatnot yeah with a